uh yo i feel like some did somebody just
try sampling sunshine or just put out
like a remix like a new version of it
am i tripping
man it's funny it's funny it's funny you
said that because
i'm trying not to give away but okay so
look maybe someone played me
a sampled version of it that it isn't
out yet or something i just feel like
it's about time somebody tries to put
remake sunshine
bruh it's crazy so
it's a two-way part to their story i'm
not gonna say who the artist is but okay
so
on the way out here though
i got a dm and an artist hit me and was
like hey man
i remade what what's your information
what you know what's going on og
and um we exchanged information then he
he called a text i text like hey this is
me like me
then he called mm-hmm you know i'm
saying i just gave the gender huh huh so
he caught success yeah yeah he called
it's a guy it's it's a guy um so he hit
me up and um
he was like man i remade
you know the record
sunshine
or i flipped it you know he was like i
gotta let you hear it
and uh we talked a little business or
whatever major artist like a major label
artist rather major major yeah yeah yeah
okay major yeah
yeah
crazy part one of his plaques in his
[__]
but i'll tell you off the air
but uh
we
will make this a bit if you can get if
you can guess
nope it's not yg nope so you you look
you owe me you owe me seven grams of
some zaza
damn i feel like someone played me a i
feel like somebody played me a record
and i was like oh some it's about time
someone flipped it
and it's it's so crazy people though
that happened the other day now a year
ago another artist
was working on a project and hit me and
his producer was like hey
it's such a great record and you know
what's crazy about that record is it's
like to this day it still is such a
great gold record that radio stations
have to play
because it's it's like
it's just one of those ones it's like
it's never going to go away yeah and i
love when it come on the way it
possessed ladies and stuff
but but the other artist hit me like a
year ago his producing we i actually had
recorded a verse on that version
so it's two artists that contacted me to
do it the other one i don't know it
didn't come out or whatever whatever but
uh